selamat kembali ke Understanding Quantum Information and Computation nama saya John Watrous dan saya Pengarah Teknikal untuk Pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini adalah pelajaran ke-16 dan terakhir dalam siri ini dan topik pelajaran ini adalah pengkomputeran kuantum tahan ralat
dalam tiga pelajaran sebelumnya kita telah melihat beberapa contoh kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang boleh mengesan dan membolehkan kita
membetulkan ralat kuantum selagi tidak terlalu banyak yang berlaku jika kita ingin menggunakan pembetulan ralat untuk pengkomputeran kuantum walau bagaimanapun masih ada banyak
isu yang perlu ditangani termasuk hakikat bahawa gate kuantum pengukuran dan penyediaan keadaan kita
sendiri berkemungkinan tidak sempurna jadi sebagai contoh jika kita ingin melakukan pembetulan ralat pada satu
atau lebih qubit yang telah dikodkan menggunakan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum maka kita perlu melakukan itu dengan gate dan pengukuran yang sendirinya
ada peluang tidak berfungsi dengan betul dan itu bermakna bukan sahaja gagal mengesan atau membetulkan ralat tapi mungkin juga
memperkenalkan ralat baru selain itu kita juga perlu melakukan pengkomputeran sebenar yang kita minat lakukan sekali lagi dengan gate yang tidak
sempurna dan kita tentu tidak boleh mengambil risiko menyahkodkan maklumat kuantum demi melakukan pengkomputeran dan kemudian
mengkodkan semula apabila selesai kerana ralat mungkin menyerang apabila perlindungan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum tiada
itu bermakna kita perlu mengetahui cara melakukan gate kuantum terus pada qubit logik yang tidak pernah tanpa
perlindungan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum ini adalah tugasan yang berat tapi diketahui bahawa selagi tahap hingar
berada di bawah nilai ambang tertentu ia sebenarnya mungkin untuk melakukan pengkomputeran kuantum yang sangat besar dengan boleh dipercayai menggunakan perkakasan yang bising sekurang-kurangnya
dari segi teori dan kita akan bincangkan fakta yang sangat penting ini kemudian dalam pelajaran ini adalah gambaran ringkas
pelajaran kita akan mulakan dengan model asas untuk pengkomputeran kuantum tahan ralat termasuk perbincangan ringkas
mengenai model hingar bersama dengan metodologi umum untuk melaksanakan litar kuantum secara tahan
ralat kemudian kita akan beralih kepada isu penyebaran ralat dalam litar kuantum tahan ralat dan cara
mengawalnya khususnya saya akan membincangkan pelaksanaan gate transversal yang menawarkan cara yang sangat mudah untuk mengawal penyebaran ralat
walaupun ada had asas yang menghalang kita daripada menggunakan kaedah ini
secara eksklusif saya juga akan bercakap tentang metodologi berbeza yang melibatkan apa yang dipanggil magic states yang menawarkan laluan berbeza untuk mengawal penyebaran ralat
dalam litar kuantum tahan ralat walaupun ia bukan satu-satunya kaedah yang diketahui dan akhirnya pelajaran
berakhir dengan perbincangan peringkat tinggi mengenai teorem ambang yang saya singgung sebentar tadi
teorem ini menyatakan bahawa litar kuantum yang sangat besar boleh dilaksanakan dengan boleh dipercayai selagi kadar ralat semua komponen
yang terlibat berada di bawah nilai ambang terhingga tertentu secara umum nilai ambang ini
bergantung pada kod pembetulan ralat yang kita gunakan serta pilihan khusus yang kita buat untuk pelaksanaan tahan ralat
gate kuantum dan pengukuran tapi bukan pada saiz litar yang dilaksanakan dan ini memberi kita sebab kukuh untuk percaya bahawa pengkomputeran kuantum berskala besar
akan menjadi kenyataan suatu hari nanti kita akan mulakan dengan membincangkan model asas untuk pengkomputeran kuantum tahan ralat
yang secara semulajadi berasaskan litar kuantum dan kod pembetulan ralat kuantum untuk tujuan perbincangan ini
mari kita bayangkan kita ada litar kuantum yang ingin kita laksanakan seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini ini kebetulan
adalah litar teleportasi termasuk penyediaan EBIT tapi butir-butirnya tidak begitu penting untuk perbincangan ini dan kamu boleh bayangkan
ini adalah mana-mana litar kuantum lain mungkin litar yang jauh lebih besar yang termasuk penyediaan keadaan operasi unitari
dan pengukuran litar ini sudah tentu mewakili ideal dan pelaksanaan
sebenarnya tidak akan sempurna soalan semulajadi yang perlu ditanya ialah apa yang mungkin boleh
salah nah ada banyak perkara yang boleh salah sebagai contoh permulaan keadaan umumnya tidak akan
sempurna sudah tentu gate unitari tidak akan sempurna dan begitu juga
pengukuran dan selain itu qubit sendiri akan terdedah kepada hingar termasuk dekoherensi pada setiap titik dalam
pengkomputeran walaupun apabila tiada yang berlaku pada qubit ini dan mereka hanya menyimpan maklumat kuantum dengan kata lain hampir
segala-galanya boleh salah ada satu pengecualian walau bagaimanapun atau sekurang-kurangnya itulah andaian biasa dan
iaitu sebarang pengkomputeran klasikal yang terlibat mungkin tidak akan rosak kerana untuk semua tujuan dan
maksud pengkomputeran klasikal pada dasarnya sempurna jadi sebagai contoh jika kita menjalankan algoritma padanan klasikal untuk
mengira pembetulan untuk ralat surface code kita benar-benar tidak perlu risau bahawa pengkomputeran klasikal ini mungkin rosak tapi apa-apa yang secara langsung
melibatkan maklumat kuantum boleh jadi rosak sudah tentu kita memerlukan model yang tepat melaluinya kita boleh mengaitkan
kebarangkalian untuk pelbagai perkara yang boleh salah dan jika kita mahu kita boleh mencipta model yang sekompleks yang kita suka untuk diharap mencerminkan apa yang
sebenarnya berlaku dalam realiti jika model itu terlalu kompleks walau bagaimanapun ia mungkin menjadi sukar atau mustahil untuk digunakan atau untuk mengatakan
apa-apa yang menarik tentangnya satu contoh model hingar yang sangat mudah yang sering dipertimbangkan
adalah model hingar stokastik bebas di mana ralat atau kegagalan yang mempengaruhi komponen berbeza pada masa yang berbeza
atau dengan kata lain lokasi berbeza dalam litar adalah bebas
sebagai contoh kita boleh mengatakan bahawa setiap gate gagal dengan kebarangkalian tertentu bahawa bit flip dan phase flip berlaku pada qubit yang disimpan dengan
kebarangkalian berbeza per unit masa dan sebagainya tapi andaiannya adalah tiada korelasi antara
ralat yang berbeza kini kamu mungkin membantah model itu kerana mungkin akan ada beberapa korelasi di antara
ralat sebagai contoh mungkin ada peluang kecil berlakunya ralat bencana yang menyapu semua qubit sekaligus
atau mungkin lebih mungkin boleh ada ralat yang setempat tetapi tetap mempengaruhi berbilang komponen
dan tiada siapa pun yang mencadangkan sebaliknya tapi walau bagaimanapun model ini mewakili garis dasar mudah yang pada
dasarnya mewakili idea bahawa alam semulajadi tidak boleh diramal tapi ia tidak berniat jahat dan tidak cuba secara sengaja
merosakkan pengkomputeran kuantum terdapat model hingar lain yang boleh dikatakan lebih realistik yang sering dipertimbangkan dan tanpa mengira
model yang kita pilih jika ternyata model kita mengelirukan kita dan kita belajar sesuatu yang baru tentang ralat dalam
sistem mana pun yang kita kerjakan kita secara semulajadi boleh merumuskan dan mempertimbangkan model ralat yang berbeza seterusnya kita akan
melihat strategi asas untuk melaksanakan litar kuantum secara tahan ralat jadi mari kita pertimbangkan
litar kuantum logik yang diberikan bermakna litar kuantum ideal yang kita minat jalankan sebagai contoh kita boleh pertimbangkan litar yang sama seperti
sebelumnya yang kini direnggangkan sedikit kerana kita memerlukan sedikit lebih banyak ruang untuk pelaksanaan tahan ralatnya pertama
WEBVTT
penyediaan keadaan gate unitari dan pengukuran tidak akan dilakukan secara langsung sebagai gate tunggal atau sebagai
pengukuran qubit tunggal atau penyediaan keadaan tapi sebaliknya ia akan dilakukan oleh apa yang dipanggil gadget yang
masing-masing boleh melibatkan berbilang qubit dan berbilang operasi di sini dalam rajah ini saya telah
mengilustrasikan ini dengan melukis kotak ungu di sekeliling benda-benda ini dan kamu boleh fikirkan kotak ungu ini sebagai litar atau operasi kecil yang
hanya dilabelkan dengan apa sahaja penyediaan keadaan atau gate yang kita ingin laksanakan kedua kita perlu melindungi
qubit menggunakan kod pembetulan ralat jadi bukannya qubit logik itu sendiri yang menghubungkan gadget-gadget berbeza ini tapi sebaliknya gadget bertindak pada
qubit fizikal yang mengkodkan qubit logik ini dan berbaloi untuk menekankan di sini bahawa qubit logik yang kita
ambil berat tidak pernah terdedah bermakna qubit logik ini akan menghabiskan seluruh hayat mereka dilindungi oleh apa sahaja
kod pembetulan ralat kuantum yang kita gunakan dan akhirnya kita melakukan pembetulan ralat pada qubit yang dikodkan kita
berulang kali sepanjang pengkomputeran pada dasarnya setiap kali kita ada peluang dan sangat penting bahawa kita
melakukan ini secara intuitif apabila ralat berlaku kerawakan atau ketidakpastian mula terbina dalam keadaan qubit kita
dan kita perlu sentiasa bekerja untuk menghapus kerawakan atau entropi ini dan ini berlaku melalui pembetulan ralat
jadi kamu boleh anggap langkah pembetulan ralat ini sebagai seperti peti sejuk logik kecil atau pam haba yang
membolehkan qubit logik kekal sejuk supaya pengkomputeran dapat berjalan dengan betul
apabila semua pilihan ini telah dibuat bermakna pemilihan semua gadget serta kod dan mengandaikan model hingar tertentu terdapat
soalan asas yang boleh kita tanya kepada diri sendiri dan iaitu adakah ini sebenarnya membantu adakah kita menjadikan sesuatu lebih baik atau
adakah kita menjadikan sesuatu lebih buruk jika ada terlalu banyak hingar kita boleh jadi memburukkan keadaan
seperti kod Shore 9Q memburukkan keadaan jika peluang ralat terlalu tinggi
tapi jika hingar berada di bawah ambang tertentu maka semua kerja tambahan ini akan membawa kita ke suatu tempat dan seperti yang akan kita bincangkan ke arah hujung pelajaran
laluan terbuka untuk pengurangan ralat lebih lanjut dalam bahagian pelajaran ini kita akan membincangkan penyebaran ralat dalam litar kuantum tahan
ralat yang mempunyai struktur asas yang baru saya huraikan ini ternyata merupakan
kebimbangan utama kerana jika kita tidak berjaya mengawal penyebaran ralat ralat akan cepat menguasai usaha pembetulan ralat kita
tapi jika kita dapat mengawal penyebaran ralat maka kod kita akan ada peluang yang jauh lebih baik
untuk mengikuti supaya ralat boleh diperbetulkan pada kadar yang cukup tinggi untuk membolehkan pengkomputeran kita
berjalan titik permulaan untuk perbincangan ini adalah kesedaran bahawa gate dua qubit atau gate berbilang qubit lebih
umum boleh menyebarkan ralat walaupun apabila ia berfungsi dengan betul
sebagai contoh pertimbangkan gate CNOT dan katakanlah ralat-X berlaku pada qubit kawalan sebelum gate CNOT
dilakukan nah ralat-X berfungsi sama seperti gate-X dan kita dapati bahawa
litar di sebelah kiri bersamaan dengan yang di sebelah kanan di mana ralat-X berlaku pada kedua-dua qubit selepas CNOT
ini adalah penyebaran ralat kerana lokasi ralat-X yang malang di sebelah kiri secara efektif mengubahnya
menjadi dua ralat-X di sebelah kanan dan kita tidak akan pernah dapat mengelakkan ini selagi kita menggunakan gate CNOT selalu akan ada
peluang ralat-X berlaku pada qubit kawalan tepat sebelumnya yang kemudian menyebar menjadi dua ralat-X
selepas itu tapi seperti yang akan kita lihat selagi kita mengambil langkah untuk menghadkan kerosakan yang ini menyebabkan kita akan baik-baik sahaja dan ngomong-ngomong
fenomena yang sama berlaku apabila kita ada ralat-Z pada qubit target tepat sebelum CNOT dan kita bincangkan ini
awal tadi dan kamu boleh semak persamaan ini dengan hanya melakukan pendaraban atau kamu boleh semak menggunakan
Qiskit kesimpulannya ialah ini dalam kedua-dua kes akan menyebabkan ralat berkorelasi pada berbilang qubit dan tentu saja kita
tidak sepatutnya lupa bahawa gate CNOT sendiri juga boleh rosak yang juga boleh menyebabkan ralat berkorelasi
menambah kebimbangan kita gate dua qubit berikutnya mungkin menyebarkan ralat ini lebih jauh lagi
sebagai contoh jika kita ada tiga gate CNOT seperti ini seperti yang kita jumpa apabila kita mengukur penjana X-stabilizer sebagai contoh maka satu ralat boleh
cepat menyebar ke berbilang qubit dan jika ini berlaku dalam satu blok kod tunggal sebagai contoh bermakna sekumpulan
qubit yang bersama-sama mengkodkan qubit logik apa sahaja kod pembetulan ralat yang kita pilih tidak akan ada
peluang kerana kod direka untuk membetulkan ralat berbobot rendah bukan ralat berbobot tinggi seperti ini
dan jadi ini adalah sesuatu yang perlu kita ingat di hadapan dan tengah sebenarnya apabila kita memikirkan tentang gadget dan
langkah pembetulan ralat dalam litar kuantum tahan ralat cara paling mudah yang diketahui untuk mengurangkan penyebaran ralat dalam litar kuantum tahan
ralat adalah melaksanakan gate secara transversal dan saya akan jelaskan maksudnya
sebentar lagi jadi mari kita kekalkan gambar pelaksanaan litar tahan ralat kita pada skrin sebagai bantuan visual sahaja
ideanya ialah untuk sesetengah kod pembetulan ralat kuantum gate-gate tertentu boleh dilaksanakan secara transversal yang
bermaksud melaksanakannya menggunakan gadget yang merupakan hasil tensor operasi di mana setiap operasi hanya bertindak pada
satu kedudukan qubit tunggal dalam setiap blok kod ini paling mudah dijelaskan melalui beberapa contoh contoh pertama dan
boleh dikatakan paling mudah adalah pelaksanaan transversal gate Pauli
ideanya ialah kita ingin membina gadget untuk setiap gate dalam litar kita dan dalam semua kes gadget itu
beroperasi pada blok kod seperti yang kita lihat untuk gate-X dan gate-Z di hujung litar teleportasi kita sudah tentu kita
tidak boleh menyahkodkan menggunakan gate Pauli dan kemudian mengkodkan semula kerana itu akan meninggalkan qubit logik tidak dilindungi dan ralat
mungkin menyebar dalam blok kod akibat pengkodan semula
mujurlah kita tidak perlu melakukan itu selagi kita menggunakan kod stabilizer kerana setiap kod stabilizer membolehkan operasi Pauli
diterapkan terus pada qubit logik kita dan sebenarnya kita boleh melakukan itu dengan hasil tensor gate Pauli
pada qubit fizikal yang digunakan untuk pengekodan
sebagai contoh jika kita mempertimbangkan surface code 3x3 yang muncul di hujung pelajaran sebelumnya maka kita boleh melaksanakan gate-X dan gate-Z pada qubit logik
yang dikodkan oleh kod ini dengan meng-tensor bersama gate-X dan gate-Z bersama-sama dengan gate identiti dalam corak yang
dicadangkan di sini ini adalah pelaksanaan transversal gate-gate ini kerana setiap satu operasi gate individu ini
hanya bertindak pada satu kedudukan qubit tunggal dalam setiap blok kod
WEBVTT
kita hanya menggunakan gate qubit tunggal di sini jadi ia agak remeh dalam satu cara tapi walau bagaimanapun gadget seperti ini tidak akan menyebabkan ralat
menyebar kini mana-mana gate individu dalam gadget seperti ini boleh gagal dan itu akan memperkenalkan
ralat tapi kita akan sentiasa melakukan pembetulan ralat sejurus selepas setiap gadget dan selagi kadar ralat
cukup rendah kod pembetulan ralat akan membetulkan ralat itu
dan seperti yang saya katakan ini sentiasa mungkin untuk gate Pauli bagi setiap kod stabilizer
walaupun kamu memang perlu mengenal pasti corak gate Pauli yang betul dalam gadget untuk melaksanakan dengan betul apa sahaja operasi Pauli logik yang kamu inginkan
untuk contoh lain yang melibatkan gate dua qubit kali ini kita boleh mempertimbangkan pelaksanaan transversal
gate CNOT khususnya untuk setiap kod CSS kita sentiasa boleh melaksanakan gate CNOT
antara dua qubit logik dengan hanya melakukan gate CNOT pada pasangan qubit fizikal yang berkaitan
dan ini memenuhi syarat transversal kerana setiap gate CNOT individu ini hanya bertindak
pada satu kedudukan qubit tunggal dalam setiap blok kod sebagai contoh gate CNOT pertama hanya bertindak pada qubit paling atas
dalam setiap blok kod gate CNOT kedua hanya bertindak pada qubit kedua dari atas dan seterusnya
dalam kes ini kita boleh ada penyebaran ralat kerana gate CNOT menyebarkan ralat dan tiada
cara untuk mencegah itu tapi kuncinya ialah penyebaran ralat tidak pernah berlaku dalam satu blok kod tunggal sebagai contoh
ralat-X boleh berlaku pada qubit atas blok kod atas tepat sebelum gadget dilakukan dan CNOT pertama
dalam gadget akan menyebarkan ralat itu ke qubit atas dalam blok bawah tapi dua ralat yang terhasil adalah
kini dalam blok kod berasingan jadi langkah pembetulan ralat yang berlaku selepas gadget akan dapat membetulkan ralat tersebut secara individu kerana ralat itu
hanya mempengaruhi satu qubit dalam setiap blok kod
sebaliknya jika penyebaran ralat berlaku dalam blok kod yang sama maka kita mungkin dalam masalah kerana
penyebaran ralat kemudiannya mengubah ralat berbobot rendah menjadi ralat berbobot lebih tinggi yang kod kita mungkin tidak dapat tangani
pelaksanaan ini tidak berfungsi untuk kod bukan-CSS tapi selagi kita menggunakan kod CSS kita sentiasa boleh melaksanakan gate CNOT
secara transversal dengan cara ini dan untuk satu lagi contoh setiap
gate Clifford boleh dilaksanakan secara transversal untuk kod Steane dan sebenarnya untuk mana-mana color code yang merupakan salah satu perkara yang benar-benar menyenangkan tentang color code
khususnya gate Hadamard pada qubit logik boleh dilaksanakan dengan melakukan gate Hadamard secara individu pada
setiap qubit fizikal dan gate-S logik boleh dilaksanakan bukan dengan gate-S pada setiap qubit tapi sebaliknya oleh
gate S-dagger pada setiap qubit fizikal jadi kesimpulannya ialah pelaksanaan gate transversal secara intrinsik
tahan ralat kerana ia tidak pernah menyebarkan ralat dalam satu blok kod tunggal yang memberi langkah pembetulan ralat peluang untuk membetulkan
apa sahaja ralat yang diperkenalkan atau disebarkan oleh gate yang digunakan untuk gadget ini jadi itu bagus dan ia adalah
cara yang sangat mudah untuk membina gadget tahan ralat dan terdapat kod berbeza yang membolehkan pelaksanaan transversal gate berbeza seperti
gate-T tapi malangnya mustahil untuk mana-mana kod bukan-trivial melaksanakan set
gate universal secara transversal yang merupakan fakta yang dikenali sebagai teorem Eastin-Knill dalam istilah teknikal yang lebih apa yang dikatakannya
ialah selagi kod kita mempunyai jarak sekurang-kurangnya dua set gate yang boleh dilaksanakan secara transversal semestinya akan menjana
set diskrit operasi sehingga fasa global dan oleh itu set ini bukan universal kerana set gate universal
semestinya menjana infiniti banyak operasi saya tidak akan menerangkan bukti teorem ini yang menggunakan beberapa
fakta asas tentang kumpulan Lie dan algebra Lie yang bukan prasyarat untuk siri ini tapi idea asasnya ialah
keluarga infiniti operasi transversal tidak mungkin membuat kita kekal dalam ruang kod kerana perbezaan halus
dalam operasi transversal dianggapi dengan baik oleh operasi Pauli berbobot rendah yang kod mengesannya sebagai
ralat jadi kita sangat gembira apabila kita boleh melaksanakan gate secara transversal tapi untuk kod mana pun yang kita pilih kita tahu bahawa kita
akan selalu ada beberapa gate yang tidak boleh kita laksanakan dengan cara ini dan jadi kita perlu mencari gadget alternatif mengikut
teorem Eastin-Knill kita tahu bahawa mustahil untuk melaksanakan set universal gate kuantum secara transversal bahkan
untuk kod pembetulan ralat kuantum jarak 2 yang kecil jadi kita perlu mencari cara lain untuk melaksanakan gate secara tahan
ralat sekurang-kurangnya untuk sesetengah gate satu cara yang terkenal untuk melakukan ini adalah melalui penggunaan apa yang dipanggil magic states
untuk tujuan perbincangan ini mari kita ingat semula gate-S dan gate-T yang merupakan
gate qubit tunggal yang ditakrifkan seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin mari kita juga perhatikan bahawa pertama gate-S adalah operasi Clifford
yang mengikut daripada definisi kita tentang operasi Clifford tapi kamu juga boleh semak bahawa mengkonjugat matriks Pauli dengan gate-S sentiasa memberi kita tambah atau tolak matriks Pauli yang lain
dan kedua gate-T bukan operasi Clifford dan sebenarnya jika kita gabungkan gate-T dengan gate Hadamard dan CNOT kedua-duanya
adalah operasi Clifford kita mendapat set universal gate kuantum jadi kita tidak boleh melaksanakan gate-T
menggunakan operasi Clifford sahaja dan pengukuran asas standard tapi kita sebenarnya boleh melaksanakan gate-T menggunakan
operasi Clifford dan pengukuran asas standard jika sebagai tambahan kita ada salinan keadaan yang ditunjukkan di sini pada
skrin iaitu gate-T diterapkan pada keadaan plus
keadaan ini dipanggil magic state walaupun ia tidak unik dalam hal itu
istilah magic state juga digunakan untuk merujuk kepada keadaan berbeza yang memainkan peranan yang serupa dengan ini dalam variasi keseluruhan
skim ini sebagai contoh litar yang ditunjukkan di sini melakukan tugasnya dan tidak terlalu sukar untuk menyemak
itu ini adalah keadaan awal dengan sistem atas di sebelah kanan dan jika kita menerapkan gate CNOT dan memudahkan kita mendapat
keadaan yang ditunjukkan di sini
jadi jika kita mengukur qubit bawah dan mendapat sifar yang berlaku dengan kebarangkalian setengah kita tidak melakukan
gate-S dan outputnya adalah gate-T diterapkan pada s
dan jika kita mengukur satu yang juga berlaku dengan kebarangkalian setengah sudah tentu kita memang menerapkan gate-S dan hasilnya
adalah outputnya sekali lagi gate-T diterapkan pada s ini bukan satu-satunya cara untuk melakukan ini ngomong-ngomong terdapat litar serupa yang lain
yang mencapai tugasan yang sama tapi ia adalah satu cara untuk melakukannya
ini adalah contoh yang agak dipermudahkan daripada sesuatu yang dikenali sebagai teleportasi gate kuantum yang saya singgung semasa pelajaran 4 di mana teleportasi digunakan
WEBVTT
bukan untuk menghantar qubit tapi untuk menerapkan gate kaitan dengan teleportasi mungkin tidak begitu jelas di sini kerana seperti yang saya
katakan ini adalah versi yang dipermudahkan yang kita boleh guna kerana gate-T adalah pepenjuru tapi jika kamu berminat untuk
mengetahui lebih lanjut kata kuncinya adalah teleportasi gate kuantum
dan kita juga boleh melakukan sesuatu yang serupa untuk melaksanakan gate-S di mana kali ini satu-satunya gate yang kita perlukan adalah gate CNOT dan gate-Z bersama dengan pengukuran
yang berguna jika kita tidak ada pelaksanaan transversal gate-S jadi itu menarik tapi tidak
begitu jelas bahawa ini sebenarnya membantu dalam kes pelaksanaan gate-T sebagai contoh kita
berjaya menerapkan gate-T pada keadaan input tapi untuk melakukan itu kita nampaknya menerapkan gate-T pada keadaan plus untuk mendapatkan
magic state dan situasi serupa untuk pelaksanaan gate-S tapi intinya ialah kita
tidak semestinya perlu mula-mula mencipta keadaan plus dan kemudian menerapkan gate-T untuk mendapatkan magic state terdapat cara lain yang mungkin untuk mendapatkan keadaan ini dan
khususnya kita boleh melakukan ini tanpa perlu risau tentang penyebaran ralat dalam pengkomputeran mana pun yang kita kerjakan kerana magic states boleh dicipta
secara berasingan ini membolehkan pelaksanaan tahan ralat bagi gate-T seperti yang akan saya huraikan secara ringkas sekarang
pertama kita sebenarnya tidak akan menjalankan litar dua qubit mudah yang ditunjukkan di sini tapi sebaliknya kita akan menjalankan litar ini menggunakan
qubit yang dikodkan dalam kod pembetulan ralat mana pun yang kita gunakan untuk pelaksanaan tahan ralat kita yang bermaksud bahawa
gate unitari dan pengukuran dilakukan oleh gadget tahan ralat dan itu bermakna kita juga memerlukan
magic states kita untuk dikodkan juga jadi semuanya akan tahan ralat selagi kita boleh dapatkan
magic states yang dikodkan kita mengandaikan di sini ngomong-ngomong bahawa kita sudah ada gadget tahan ralat untuk gate-S jika
kita menggunakan kod Steane sebagai contoh kita boleh hanya melaksanakan gate-S secara transversal dan untuk kod yang mana itu tidak berfungsi satu pilihan adalah
mula-mula menggunakan keseluruhan skim ini untuk melaksanakan gate-S secara tahan ralat dan kemudian menggunakan pelaksanaan itu di sini
walaupun itu bukan satu-satunya pilihan tapi walau bagaimanapun kembali kepada pelaksanaan soalan penting yang tinggal ialah bagaimana kita mendapatkan
magic state yang dikodkan memandangkan kita belum ada pelaksanaan tahan ralat gate-T untuk menjadikannya
mudah dan idea utamanya ialah kita boleh menggunakan proses probabilistik untuk mencipta magic states yang dikodkan dan jika ia tidak
berlaku dengan baik maka tidak apa kita boleh buang sahaja percubaan yang gagal dan cuba lagi
dan itu tidak mengganggu pengkomputeran yang sebenarnya kita cuba lakukan kerana penciptaan magic states dilakukan
secara berasingan cara biasa ini dilakukan adalah melalui proses yang dikenali sebagai penyulingan magic state dan ia berfungsi seperti
ini kita ada litar tertentu yang dikenali sebagai penyuling kita masukkan ke dalam penyuling ini koleksi magic states yang bising
dan kemudian ukur semua kecuali satu output dan jika kita bersyarat pada semua hasil pengukuran adalah sifar
maka apa yang berlaku ialah yang keluar adalah magic state yang kurang bising yang kemudiannya boleh menjadi salah satu qubit yang dimasukkan ke dalam
penyuling yang lain dan proses berlanjutan sehingga sama ada kita gagal kerana salah satu hasil pengukuran adalah bukan sifar dan kita cuba lagi atau kita ada magic
state yang berkualiti cukup tinggi supaya kita boleh menggunakannya dengan selamat untuk melaksanakan gate-T dalam pengkomputeran yang kita ambil berat
terdapat cara berbeza yang diketahui untuk membina penyuling seperti ini tapi semuanya berfungsi pada dasarnya dengan cara yang sama iaitu ia adalah penyahkod untuk kod stabilizer
bermakna ia adalah songsangan litar pengekodan yang menyenangkan kerana itu bermakna penyuling boleh menjadi operasi Clifford
dan akhirnya proses penyulingan ini sebenarnya berlaku pada peringkat qubit logik jadi dalam realiti ia
semua dilakukan menggunakan gadget untuk penyuling dan pengukuran proses ini memang perlu bermula dari suatu titik tapi selagi kadar hingar tidak terlalu tinggi adalah mungkin untuk mencipta magic states yang bising tetapi cukup baik
untuk memulakannya sebagai contoh dengan menerapkan gate-T bising yang sebenar pada qubit dalam keadaan plus dan kemudian
mengkodkan qubit itu jadi itu adalah huraian peringkat tinggi tetapi semoga saya telah memberi kamu gambaran kasar tentang cara ini berjalan
ia agak lebih rumit daripada melaksanakan gate secara transversal tapi walau bagaimanapun ia menawarkan cara untuk melaksanakan set universal gate kuantum
secara tahan ralat manakala pelaksanaan gate transversal sahaja tidak boleh melakukannya kadang-kadang
didakwa bahawa overhed untuk menggunakan magic states bagi melaksanakan gate secara tahan ralat sejajar ini akan sangat tinggi
di mana sebahagian besar kerja pergi kepada penyulingan magic states dan menjalankan pengkomputeran sebenar adalah lebih kepada
renungan belakang tapi itu sebenarnya tidak begitu jelas dan terdapat analisis terperinci yang mendedahkan bahawa kaedah ini
sebenarnya boleh menjadi praktikal terdapat beberapa skim lain yang diketahui untuk melaksanakan gate secara tahan ralat deformasi kod dan penukaran kod adalah nama
yang dikaitkan dengan beberapa skim ini dan cara baru terus dibangunkan dan diperhalusi tapi saya tidak akan huraikan kaedah itu
dalam pelajaran ini terdapat satu lagi isu penting mengenai pelaksanaan tahan ralat litar kuantum dan
ia berkaitan dengan langkah pembetulan ralat itu sendiri jadi ini bukan tentang melaksanakan gate ia adalah tentang melakukan
pembetulan ralat yang sebenar masalahnya ialah jika kita memikirkan litar mudah yang
pertama kali kita lihat dalam pelajaran 14 untuk mengukur penjana stabilizer berdasarkan anggaran fasa kita dapati bahawa ia tidak
sendiri tahan ralat kerana ia berpotensi menyebabkan ralat menyebar dalam satu blok kod tunggal
ini kembali kepada idea bahawa apa-apa yang melibatkan maklumat kuantum terdedah kepada ralat dan itu termasuk litar yang sendirinya bertujuan
untuk membetulkan ralat ini nampaknya agak bermasalah tapi sebenarnya terdapat berbilang penyelesaian yang diketahui untuk masalah ini saya akan menyebut beberapa sahaja
walaupun saya tidak akan menerangkan mana-mana daripadanya secara terperinci dan ngomong-ngomong jika kamu mendapat idea bahawa pengkomputeran kuantum tahan ralat adalah
rumit dan ada banyak perincian yang perlu dibimbangkan maka itu pasti boleh difahami kerana itu benar ada banyak bahagian bergerak
di sini dan niat saya dengan pelajaran ini bukan untuk menerangkan semua perincian tapi sebaliknya memberi kamu hanya pengenalan asas tentang cara ia semua
berfungsi satu kaedah untuk pembetulan ralat kuantum tahan ralat dikenali sebagai pembetulan ralat Shore dinamakan sempena Peter
Shore yang pertama mencadangkan kaedah ini ideanya adalah melakukan setiap pengukuran sindrom menggunakan apa yang dipanggil cat state
yang merupakan perkara yang sama seperti keadaan GHZ apabila kita ada tiga qubit tapi ia boleh digeneralisasikan ke mana-mana bilangan qubit yang sepadan dengan berat penjana stabilizer
yang kita ingin ukur khususnya litar yang ditunjukkan di sini berfungsi untuk mengukur penjana stabilizer dan boleh
ditunjukkan bahawa kaedah ini tidak menyebabkan ralat menyebar dalam blok kod
ia memerlukan penciptaan cat state itu sendiri dan untuk membuatnya berfungsi dengan boleh dipercayai dalam kehadiran ralat dan gate yang berpotensi rosak kaedah ini sebenarnya
memerlukan kita berulang kali menjalankan litar seperti ini dan membuat inferens tentang di mana pelbagai ralat mungkin berlaku semasa
proses itu kaedah alternatif dikenali sebagai pembetulan ralat Steane yang pertama dicadangkan oleh Andrew Steane dan
kaedah ini berfungsi secara berbeza dan ia hanya berfungsi untuk kod CSS dalam kaedah ini kita sebenarnya tidak melakukan pengukuran sindrom pada keadaan kuantum yang dikodkan
WEBVTT
dalam litar yang kita cuba jalankan tapi sebaliknya kita sengaja menyebarkan ralat ke sistem workspace
dan kemudian mengukur sistem itu dan mengesan ralat secara klasikal gambar yang ditunjukkan di sini menunjukkan cara melakukan ini untuk ralat-X di mana qubit workspace
pada mulanya ditetapkan kepada pengekodan keadaan plus jadi ini pada dasarnya adalah
pelaksanaan transversal gate CNOT yang sepatutnya tidak melakukan apa-apa kerana target berada dalam keadaan plus tapi jika ada
ralat-X dalam qubit atas mereka akan menyebar ke bawah ke sistem bawah dan akan dikesan terdapat juga kaedah serupa untuk mengesan ralat-Z
dan yang tidak ditunjukkan di sini terdapat juga kaedah berkaitan yang dikenali sebagai pembetulan ralat Knill yang pertama dicadangkan oleh Manny Knill
dan ia berasaskan teleportasi dan bukannya CNOT transversal dan itu membolehkannya berfungsi untuk kod stabilizer sewenang-wenangnya
dan bukan hanya kod CSS
perkara terakhir yang akan saya bincangkan dalam pelajaran ini adalah teorem yang sangat penting yang dikenali sebagai teorem ambang ini adalah pernyataan
yang agak tidak rasmi teorem ini menyatakan bahawa jika kita ada mana-mana litar kuantum yang mempunyai n gate di mana n boleh sebesar yang kita suka maka ia adalah
mungkin untuk melaksanakan litar itu dengan ketepatan tinggi menggunakan litar kuantum yang bising dengan syarat bahawa tahap hingar
adalah di bawah nilai ambang tertentu yang bebas daripada n dan selain itu tidak terlalu mahal untuk melakukan ini dalam
erti kata bahawa saiz litar bising yang diperlukan adalah berkadar dengan n kali kuasa malar logaritma
n untuk menyatakan teorem itu dengan lebih formal memerlukan ketepatan mengenai model hingar yang saya tidak akan lakukan dalam pelajaran ini
ia boleh sebagai contoh dibuktikan untuk model hingar stokastik bebas yang saya sebut awal tadi di mana ralat berlaku
secara bebas pada setiap lokasi yang mungkin dalam litar dengan beberapa kebarangkalian yang lebih kecil secara ketat daripada nilai ambang ini tapi ia juga boleh
dibuktikan untuk model hingar yang lebih umum di mana boleh ada korelasi di antara ralat kini ini adalah hasil
teoritikal dan cara biasa ia dibuktikan tidak semestinya diterjemahkan kepada sesuatu yang kita sebenarnya akan lakukan dalam amalan tapi ia walau bagaimanapun adalah
teorem yang sangat penting dalam istilah praktikal dan sebabnya ialah ia pada dasarnya mengatakan bahawa tiada halangan asas untuk melakukan
pengkomputeran kuantum menggunakan komponen yang bising
selagi kadar ralat komponen ini berada di bawah nilai ambang ini ia boleh digunakan untuk membina litar kuantum yang boleh dipercayai berukuran sewenang-wenangnya
cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah jika teorem tidak benar sukar untuk membayangkan pengkomputeran kuantum berskala besar
menjadi kenyataan ada banyak perincian teknikal yang terlibat dalam bukti formal teorem ini yang saya tidak akan cuba
sampaikan tapi saya akan cuba menerangkan idea asas pada peringkat tinggi dan saya juga akan cuba menghubungkan secara longgar idea asas
dengan apa yang kita mungkin jangkakan berlaku dalam amalan jadi katakanlah ini adalah litar kita ia adalah litar yang sama yang
kita telah bincangkan sepanjang pelajaran tapi sekali lagi kita boleh bayangkan bahawa litar kita jauh lebih besar dan lebih rumit daripada ini kita ingin
melaksanakan litar ini tapi semua komponen kita bising dan mengandaikan kita menggunakan model hingar stokastik bebas
hanya untuk kesederhanaan ada beberapa kebarangkalian P dengan mana ralat berlaku secara bebas di setiap lokasi yang mungkin
jika litar itu jauh lebih besar daripada salingan kebarangkalian P ini maka kita boleh yakin bahawa
pelaksanaan langsung tidak akan berfungsi dengan betul jadi kita menjalani semua urusan melaksanakan litar secara
tahan ralat seperti yang telah saya bincangkan hingga ke titik ini dalam pelajaran dan kita tanya kepada diri sendiri soalan yang saya bangkitkan awal tadi iaitu adakah kita menjadikan sesuatu
lebih baik atau adakah kita menjadikan sesuatu lebih buruk nah jika kebarangkalian P yang mewakili kebarangkalian ralat untuk setiap komponen kita adalah terlalu besar maka
ini tidak akan membantu seperti kod Shore 9Q tidak membantu jika kebarangkalian ralat melebihi 3 dan tiga per empat peratus atau lebih kurang
khususnya kita kini telah membuat litar lebih besar jadi ada banyak lagi lokasi di mana ralat boleh menyerang
walau bagaimanapun jika P cukup kecil ini akan membantu dan apa yang kita secara efektif akan lakukan adalah mengurangkan kebarangkalian ralat
untuk pengkomputeran logik yang kita lakukan jadi mari kita fikirkan tentang ini dalam
sedikit lebih terperinci dan untuk melihat idea utama dalam persekitaran semudah yang mungkin katakanlah kita menggunakan kod Steane 7 qubit untuk pembetulan
ralat yang membolehkan pembetulan sehingga satu ralat per blok kod jadi untuk ralat logik
berlaku dalam litar asal kita perlu ada sekurang-kurangnya dua ralat yang jatuh ke dalam blok kod yang sama untuk tahan ralat kita
pelaksanaan
mengingat bahawa terdapat banyak cara berbeza untuk ada dua atau lebih ralat dalam blok kod yang sama boleh hujahkan bahawa kebarangkalian ralat logik
pada setiap lokasi dalam litar asal adalah paling banyak C kali P kuasa 2 di mana C adalah nombor yang bergantung pada kod dan pada
gadget yang kita gunakan tapi yang penting ia tidak bergantung pada saiz litar asal
jadi jika P lebih kecil daripada salingan C yang merupakan nombor yang boleh kita ambil sebagai nilai ambang kita maka ini
diterjemahkan kepada pengurangan ralat jadi kerja keras kita dalam melaksanakan litar secara tahan ralat sedang membuahkan
hasil walau bagaimanapun kadar ralat baru ini mungkin masih terlalu tinggi untuk seluruh litar berfungsi dengan betul jadi kita perlu
buat lebih dalam amalan perkara semulajadi yang perlu dilakukan pada ketika ini adalah memilih kod yang lebih baik dan gadget yang lebih baik untuk menurunkan kadar ralat
ke titik di mana pelaksanaan berkemungkinan akan berjaya
secara teoritikal cara mudah untuk menghujahkan bahawa ini mungkin adalah dengan menghubungkan secara konkatenat dengan kata lain kita fikirkan
tentang pelaksanaan tahan ralat litar asal sebagai litar logik baru dan kemudian kita laksanakannya secara tahan
ralat dan kemudian kita melakukan ini lagi dan lagi sebanyak kali yang diperlukan dan ternyata ini mengurangkan ralat
dengan sangat cepat dan begitulah teorem ambang biasanya dibuktikan di atas kertas
saya akan beri kamu gambaran yang sangat kasar tentang cara kadar ralat berkurang meninggalkan banyak perincian teknikal yang diperlukan untuk
membuktikan ini secara formal kita bermula dengan kebarangkalian ralat P untuk komponen asal kita dan jika kita melaksanakan
litar secara tahan ralat ralat berkurang dengan faktor C kali P jika kita kemudian merawat pelaksanaan tahan ralat kita
sebagai litar logik dan melaksanakannya secara tahan ralat kita mendapat penurunan serupa dalam kadar ralat tapi
jika kita fikirkan tentang kadar ralat efektif untuk litar asal kita dapati ia turun lebih lagi kerana kini
kita menggantikan kadar ralat P dengan C kali P kuasa 2 kerana itulah kadar ralat efektif selepas pelaksanaan tahan ralat peringkat pertama
khususnya selepas sedikit algebra kita dapati bahawa ralat turun ke CP kuasa 3 kali P dan jika kita lakukan lagi kini kita ada kadar ralat CP kuasa 7 kali P dan jika
kita teruskan melakukan ini untuk jumlah K peringkat apa yang kita dapati ialah ralat mengecut secara eksponensial berganda dalam K jadi kita
tidak perlu melakukan ini banyak kali untuk menjadikan kadar ralat sangat kecil
sementara itu litar semakin besar dalam saiz tapi saiznya hanya meningkat secara eksponensial tunggal dalam K kerana dengan setiap
peringkat toleransi ralat saiz litar kita bertumbuh oleh paling banyak faktor yang ditentukan oleh saiz maksimum
gadget kita dan apabila semuanya digabungkan dan pilihan yang sesuai untuk bilangan
peringkat konkatenat dibuat kita mendapat teorem ambang tapi seperti yang sudah saya cadangkan terdapat banyak perincian yang diperlukan untuk menjadikan ini formal jadi
apakah nilai ambang ini dalam realiti nah ia bergantung pada kod dan gadget yang kita
gunakan untuk kod Steane bersama dengan penyulingan magic state ia sangat kecil dan mungkin tidak mungkin dicapai dalam
amalan tapi menggunakan surface code dan gadget terkini ia dianggarkan sekitar 1% yang tidak
buruk dan apabila kod dan kaedah baru ditemui kita boleh dengan munasabah menjangkakan ia akan meningkat sementara pada masa yang sama
tahap hingar dalam komponen yang kita bina akan berkurang mencapai titik di mana
pengkomputeran kuantum berskala besar boleh dilaksanakan secara tahan ralat tidak akan mudah dan ia tidak akan berlaku dalam sekelip mata
WEBVTT
jika kita teruskan melakukan ini untuk jumlah K peringkat apa yang kita dapati ialah ralat mengecut secara eksponensial berganda dalam K jadi kita
tidak perlu melakukan ini banyak kali untuk menjadikan kadar ralat sangat kecil
sementara itu litar semakin besar dalam saiz tapi saiznya hanya meningkat secara eksponensial tunggal dalam K kerana dengan setiap
peringkat toleransi ralat saiz litar kita bertumbuh oleh paling banyak faktor yang ditentukan oleh saiz maksimum
gadget kita dan apabila semuanya digabungkan dan pilihan yang sesuai untuk bilangan peringkat konkatenat dibuat kita mendapat teorem ambang tapi seperti yang sudah saya cadangkan terdapat banyak perincian yang diperlukan untuk menjadikan ini formal jadi
apakah nilai ambang ini dalam realiti nah ia bergantung pada kod dan gadget yang kita gunakan untuk kod Steane bersama dengan penyulingan magic state ia sangat kecil dan mungkin tidak mungkin dicapai dalam
amalan tapi menggunakan surface code dan gadget terkini ia dianggarkan sekitar 1% yang tidak
buruk dan apabila kod dan kaedah baru ditemui kita boleh dengan munasabah menjangkakan ia akan meningkat sementara pada masa yang sama
tahap hingar dalam komponen yang kita bina akan berkurang mencapai titik di mana
pengkomputeran kuantum berskala besar boleh dilaksanakan secara tahan ralat tidak akan mudah dan ia tidak akan berlaku dalam sekelip mata
tapi teorem ini bersama-sama dengan kemajuan dalam kod kuantum dan perkakasan kuantum yang telah kita saksikan hingga kini
memberikan kita optimisme yang kita perlukan untuk terus maju ke hadapan untuk mencapai matlamat muktamad membina sebuah
komputer kuantum tahan ralat berskala besar dan itulah penghujung pelajaran dan penghujung siri saya
dengan tulus harap kamu mendapati nilai dalam siri ini dan jika ada tolong pertimbangkan untuk mengesyorkannya kepada rakan sekerja atau kawan
juga pastikan kamu menyemak IBM Quantum Learning untuk kursus dan tutorial tambahan dan langgan saluran YouTube Qiskit
jika kamu belum berbuat demikian supaya kamu boleh terus dikemas kini dengan siaran kandungan masa depan kami terima kasih kerana
juga pastikan kamu menyemak IBM Quantum Learning untuk kursus dan tutorial tambahan dan langgan saluran YouTube
Qiskit jika kamu belum berbuat demikian supaya kamu boleh terus dikemas kini dengan siaran kandungan masa depan kami terima kasih kerana
menonton